I don't know what to do right now but uh
my uncle's got a bobcat
oh hell yeah
and that's a real Uncle
Homeward
it's like a pet and uh
man that thing's been coming around for
about two months now and uh
I'm gonna tell you right now
it gets Wild
because he's from the wild
oh yeah
look I'll tell you this man The Jungle
Book it ain't a book it's a damn library
son
The Jungle Book is a it's a Anthology
it's it's a billion chapters long baby
you gotta remember that an inchworm got
the same [ __ ] in it that a leopard got
in it that's all connected daddy gang
but
I'm telling you Dave I come home another
day
and he was over there he snatched my hat
off my head like real man
do something
so we figured it out they get some
jerked off every month and a half
175 dollars
to get that little Bobcat jerked off God
that's beautiful man
oh that's beautiful
you know uh
that Utah senators not going to like
that I'll say that
and I don't condone usually humans
pleasure and animal
there's videos out there they got a man
they called him what a you know and a
man and a dog dating
in a park
and that you know
I don't condone it when uh
if uh I don't condone that kind of stuff
but look if this is a bobcat if
something's gonna kill you if it doesn't
ejaculate
then you got two choices
die
or service that animal baby
nobody thinks you're a pervert if
something's going to kill you
and you make it e-jack
and then it doesn't kill you
that ain't
you know some kind of animal gay or
whatever
best safety Bob
that's damn safety dude
other than that he's good to go I just
want to let you know and thank you for
that man thank you for letting us know
I'll tell you this I'll tell you this
if they passed a a thing around my
building a chart or something you had a
guess or check yes or no
and these don't even work I don't know
why I'm wearing them if they pass that
thing around my building they said hey
there's a there is a bobcat in the
building
and and if it doesn't ejaculate
then every six weeks somebody gonna lose
a [ __ ] thumb homie
somebody gonna lose an elbow somebody
gonna lose a damn coccyx
you know what I'm saying Richard gonna
lose an eyeball baby
Libby gonna lose a Libya you know what
I'm saying bruh
then I say hey sign me up cut
I'll go first I'll reach into the box
you know
I put on a burn on one of those burn
proof mittens and reach into the box
you know in glove that little pecker out
because that's who I am bro
I'm working for God baby
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one